media reports from the British press in
the aftermath of Wednesday's truck and
knife attack on parliament resulting in
the death of at least four people in
catastrophic injuries to more than a
dozen more have focused in on the
identity of the perpetrator in vague
terms we knew according to the Telegraph
that the attacker was described by
witnesses as quote an Asian guy in about
his 40s carrying a knife about seven or
eight inches long the daily star of the
UK called the suspect a black or Asian
man who was spotted running with an
8-inch knife The Daily Mirror called him
a quote reportedly Asian in appearance
the picture of the suspect shows that he
is in fact some guy from the Middle East
or Pakistan in America Asian has a
different connotation than it does in
the British press it generally means
people of Pakistani or Indian descent
not people from Southeast Asia as it
does in the United States it's also
often a cover for Islamic background the
press will generally avoid talking about
the religion of a suspect in favor of
focusing in on ethnicity and then they
will broaden out the ethnic label to
include people who aren't Pakistani in
order to create the impression that the
Pakistani perpetrator might not be a
Muslim in May 2012 the BBC reported that
groups representing Sikhs and Hindus
complain to the media about the use of
determination to apply to nine Pakistani
suspects erected for grooming girls for
sex the network of Sikh organizations UK
the hindu forum of britain the sikh
media monitoring group UK accused the
media of unwillingness to mention the
quote disproportionate representation of
muslims in such cases and the non-muslim
identities of the victims calling the
asian label quote unfair to other
communities of asian responsibility
adding quote we believe that in this
case the government itself is
sanctioning the use of the termination
as way of clouding responsibility the
same pattern helped through in reporting
of the rotherham incident where british
authorities fearful of supposed to
backlash held back on investigations
into a serious upsurge in rape and child
sex slavery involving muslim men up to
1400 children were involved the police
files are important ones he tend to
openly mention in quote a problem with
networks of asian offenders both locally
and nationally and stated that the
crimes were related to culture from
1997a 2013 the crimes were under police
and underreported this is how media and
government turn individual criminal
issues into actual tribal conflicts by
refusing told everyone to the same
standard refusing to acknowledge that
not all cultures are equally compatible
with Western standards of decency and
said using ethnic descriptors rather
than ideological ones the media and
authorities actually drives unif obeah
rather than alleviating it as well as
sweeping up innocent people in the net
Sikhs and Hindus do not deserve to be
placed in the same risk category as
radical Muslims with regard to terrorism
attempting to protect moderate Muslims
by ignoring all ideological leanings
whatsoever is stupid and using the over
broad ethnic descriptor Asian pretending
to Indians and Pakistanis are part of
the same ethnic group for purposes of
avoiding idea logical conclusion jumping
is purposeful obfuscation of accuracy
maybe the terrorist isn't Muslim we now
know that he is that would have been
possible but it's not fine to give the
public misleading information on the
grounds that they might jump to
conclusions suggested by probabilistic
thinking and then lumpen innocent people
in the process I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show okay I'm be
spending some hot fire today because
there's a lot of line going on i'm going
to debunk all of it because it's really
maddening it's really making me upset
i'm very sick of it i am annoyed i am
frustrated everyone is lying they're all
lying to you and it is making me sick to
my stomach and so we are going to put an
end to that today when we discuss the
truth about what's happening on this
front brush of stuff and on the
wiretapping stuff and on all the rest
but on Trump care so many lies so little
time so much to get to but first we have
to say thank you to our advertisers over
a twink so if you are somebody who knows
nothing about wine like me if you're
somebody who would buy just a bottle of
grape juice that it's fermented too long
and think that that was wine number one
you don't know anything about wine
number two you need to actually go to
try wing calm / Ben because you're going
over to somebody's house and now you
need to bring a decent bottle of wine
and that old bottle of ketam ain't going
to do it so you need something that's
actually going to go with the food you
go to wing try wing calm and they ask
you what your tastes are like what kind
of flavors you like and then they
personalize a bottle to you they tell
you what bottle you will like all the
bottles of wine are cheap the staff has
tried them they say the line is really
really top-notch which is why they're
always drunk try wink calm so I spending
at twenty dollars off plus complimentary
shipping when you try wing calm
flash been and it's winc it used to be
club w it's winc wink calm / bend and
again the bottles are not random they
are personalized to your palate and and
you can rate the wine that you choose
that they won't send you the same bottle
again if you don't like the line they
will replace it with a bottle that you
like no questions asked one hundred
percent satisfaction guaranteed try wink
calm splash man they cover the shipping
for twenty bucks off right now which is
could be like two bottles so that's it
that's a pretty solid deal try wink calm
/ been terrific service particularly if
your ignorance about what wines are good
okay so so as I take lots of line going
on many a lie from all sides and it's
making me want to vomit so let's begin
with the biggest slide told by the media
last night that Donald Trump is on the
verge of impeachment it's always over
Donald's when they found the silver
bullet Anderson Cooper Anderson Cooper
is on CNN and he says we have new
information what is that new information
while we now know that the FBI may or
may not have information that Donald
Trump's team was coordinating with the
Russians in order release info on
Hillary Clinton during the campaign here
is the Silver Fox anderson cooper has
Pamela brown and Evan Perez joining us
now they broke the story along with our
justice reporter she moaned pro-q pez
Pam first what are you learning well
Anderson the FBI has information that
indicates associates of President Donald
Trump communicated with suspected
Russian operatives to possibly
coordinate the release of information
damaging to Hillary Clinton's campaign
US officials told us FBI director James
Comey made his bombshell announcement is
you'll recall Monday before Congress
that the FBI is investigating the Trump
campaign ties to Russia so the FBI is
now reviewing this information which
includes human intelligence travel
business and phone records as well as
accounts of in-person meetings according
to the official all the sounds pretty
damning right this sounds like who the
FBI has the materials can get Trump his
associates were working with the
Rooskies and then we're going to take
down Hillary Clinton Adam Schiff the
gemach ranking Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee he comes forward
and he says basically the same thing
when you admit it's a circum all you
have right now is a circumstantial case
actually no Chuck I can tell you that
the case is more
that and I can't go into the particulars
but there is more than circumstantial
evidence now so again I think so you
have fun direct evidence of collusion I
don't want to go into specifics but i
will say that there is evidence that is
not circumstantial and and is very much
worthy of investigation and it is rumor
mongering new rumor mongering here's
what the CNN report actually said the
FBI has information that indicates
associates of President Donald's from
communicated with suspected Russian
operatives to possibly coordinate the
release of information damaging to
Hillary Clinton's campaign okay so the
first sentient pre-qualifying words
indicates suspected and possibly and
then when you read down to of course
paragraph nine or ten in the article
quote one law-enforcement official said
the information in hand suggest people
connected to the campaign were in
contact and it appeared they were giving
the thumbs up to release information
when it was ready but other US officials
who spoke to CNN say it's premature to
draw that inference from the information
gathered so far since it's largely
circumstantial so no Adam chef
apparently the information is largely
circumstantial according to other US
officials they got one person saying is
not circumstantial a bunch of people
saying it is circumstantial and the
entire media running with it Trump is on
the ropes it's all over okay no it's not
come on cut it out okay so that is side
one exaggerating the case or lying or
making case have to be ironclad when it
simply is not then on the other side we
have a bunch of people saying that Trump
has been vindicated in his wiretapping
claims so no he hasn't no he hasn't can
just being honest here if you don't want
honesty there are plenty of other places
that will tell you that Trump is the the
most vindicated person who's ever lived
and all is well in all this crap okay
here is what Trump actually said from
said that like McCarthy like McCarthy
there was purposeful wiretapping of
Trump Tower and I'm not I'm going to be
specific I'm not even going to say that
it was wiretapping of Trump Tower
specifically will make the claim a
little broader will say that Trump said
that Obama directed surveillance at him
will make even broader than that Trump
said that Obama intelligence officials
directed surveillance at him and his
officials okay that's what we will say
now is there any evidence to that
whatsoever no there isn't any evidence
of that whatsoever okay all the evidence
suggests so far that if there were Trump
associates were caught
in the quote-unquote surveillance they
were caught up incidentally meaning we
don't have any pfizer warrants that we
know about other than I think one report
in like each street or something there
are no FISA warrants that we know about
they were actually directed at US
citizens on this one there's no flies
warrant that went out on Mike Flynn for
example there's no FISA warrant as far
as we know there was no direct
surveillance to these people now does
that mean that there was no surveillance
of these people know that there was
surveillance of these people in the same
way that for example you wouldn't say
that the cops were targeting you if they
were staking out a drug den and you were
a client okay they weren't targeting you
they were targeting the drug den and you
were a client okay this is the same
thing that's happening here they were
targeting the Russians and the Russians
were talking to trump people and some of
the Trump people are on the line with
the Russians that is not the same thing
as what Trump was claiming which was
Obama basically put a team on me my
friends and then he was attempting to
gather information on us so that he
could release it and take us down okay
that's not true so doesn't matter people
have gotten into this business and it's
driving me absolutely up a wall up a
freaking wall okay the left did it
during the Michael Brown Darren Wilson
scenario where they claimed hands up
don't shoot and people like me said that
never happened and love said ah you're
right it never happened but the facts
may not true be true but the narrative
is true i would say what the hell does
that mean well you show me some facts
generating a narrative and then we'll
determine if it's true you can't just
say the narrative is true without any
facts to back it up okay the right is
now doing a lot of the same stuff on
Trump surveillance Clint so it is true
factually speaking that there were
people who are in the Trump team who are
caught up in the surveillance net that
was directed at people who are not the
Trump team okay that is true you don't
have to draw a narrative from it okay
that's just a fact what is not true is
when you take Trump's original claim
that he was purposefully wired captured
by Obama and then you broaden it out to
not only include Trump but also his team
and then you broaden it out to also
include incidental collection of
information and then you claim Trump is
vindicated that's a bunch of horse crap
okay so here's what Devon nuñez said
yesterday we can go through this in
detail because I think it is important
to debunk things that are not true I
still care about things like truth even
if they don't benefit my side quote
unquote ok here is Devon nuñez he starts
off by saying that this is his big
announcement that was supposedly earth
shattered
yesterday he is the the ranking
Republican on the House Intelligence
Committee and he had just gone to the
White House and met with Trump honest I
was concerned that other surveillance
activities were used against president
Trump and his associates so first I
recently confirmed that on numerous
occasions the intelligence community
incidentally collected information about
US citizens involved in the Trump
transition details about us persons
associated with the incoming
administration details with little or no
apparent foreign intelligence value were
widely disseminated in intelligence
community reporting third I have
confirmed that additional names of Trump
transition team members were unmasked
and fourth and finally I want to be
clear none of this surveillance was
related to Russia or the investigation
of Russian activities or of the Trump
team okay so here's the important part
so that we'll get to the wiretapping
part of the leaks part in a second
because Nunez's right on the links that
is the most important part of what is
happening in all of this I agree with
that because again there is no hard
information that one obama directed
wiretapping at Trump or two that trumps
in the pocket of the Russians but what
we do know with 100-percent certitude is
that Obama intelligence officials were
leaking information to the press that is
a crime okay and those people need to be
tracked down and prosecuted because
regardless of how they got the
information on Mike Flynn being on the
phone with Syria kiss Lee a core number
his name as they were not supposed to
release that that is illegal so the last
part of what he's saying is not the
controversial part it's the first part
what did he say here is what he exactly
said again the intelligence community
incidentally collected information about
US citizens involved in the Trump
transition incidentally okay so for all
the people claiming that this vindicates
Trump know incidentally means the drug
deal i was talking about before
incidentally means that they were
listening to the Russians and some Trump
people were on the other end of the line
that is not the same thing as what Trump
claims and to pretend that it is is to
be dishonest okay and then it is
clarified okay reporter says where these
communications picked up a trump tower
pick up from power we don't know that
yet that's why we need to get the
information okay and then he is asked
specifically was Trump targeted or was
this just incidental collection of
information was he just on the other
line okay part of the design collection
is communication yes they were real
images London president united states
personal communication or intercepted
you know I think we have to I think what
we have is very when we talk about
intelligence products here we've got to
be very careful from what I know right
now it looks like incidental collection
snap at damage on the incidental
collection okay clip for are you
concerned that the surveillance was done
illegally was there anything illegal
here here's news from the surveillance
obscenity legally horseman gentle but oh
well people that's great yeah that's
that's a really good question so I
believe it was all done legally but
there again that's not what Trump is
claiming Trump is claiming that he was
illegally surveilled that's what he says
ok so again is this great stuff no but
is are you claiming the intelligence
community is doing things that they're
not doing it's Trump is doing that
that's bad it's just mind-boggling to me
that people are willing to overlook
basic truth because they want a
political agenda to win here okay I hate
this from could have easily made the
case that the leaks that are coming out
of the Obama apparatus are the problem
that was against the mark levin made
okay mark levin was right okay the case
the Trump has made is not that because
Trump reads the headline assumes what he
wants to assume and then determines that
it's true based on his gut that day he
basically said that today an interview
of time which I'm going to get to in a
second again just more fibbed mmm okay
continues he is now asked Devin Nunez
the house in health care he has asked
about whether the president's
conversation appeared in intelligence
reports experiences president
conversation
anything about the president inerrancy
intelligence report is that what you're
saying I have seen I obscene
intelligence reports that clearly show
that the president-elect and his team
were I guess that at least monitored and
disseminated out in intelligence and
what appears to be raw or but I
shouldn't say Robert intelligence
reporting channels doing is nothing
exact in his language here it's annoying
when he says his team were was monitored
people are latching on to that to say
ooh that means the Trump was right he
was surveilled except that nuñez said a
half dozen times in this press
conference that it was the Russians or
whoever was on the other he doesn't
consider the Russians he says it was
ever on the other end the line was being
surveilled and Trump was caught up
incidentally he said that a thousand
times who just played it him doing it a
bunch of times in a row okay and the
weirdest part is that Nunez actually
said it has nothing to do with the
Russian investigations also all of this
was happening between the election and
trumped inauguration okay so in other
words Trump claims Hughes wiretapped in
October purposefully by Obama not one
element of that has been verified and
not one element of that has been
verified it just hasn't again does that
mean that the leaks are okay no the
leaks are terrible and that's why it's
so stupid that everybody on the Left
keeps denying that the leaks are bad and
everybody on the right keep saying Trump
was right no none of all of its crap all
of its crap all of its crap and then
finally nunez disaster this morning he
was asked actually if he got all of this
information from the white house because
he apparently went to the White House
and gave them the information before he
gave the Intelligence Committee all this
new information supposedly that he's
breaking this clip 16 and he won't
answer the question over the course of
this investigation we've had many
sources who have come to this committee
and as you can imagine some mini don't
want you to know they don't want anyone
to know who they are and I think you
guys in the press understand this you
you
your own sources of their selfish
engineer by the prompt administration
the money to water with that yeah look I
came out here and briefed you guys
yesterday said this is what I'm going to
go do so that you knew the president
didn't invite me over I called I called
down there and invited myself because I
thought he needed to understand or what
I saw and that he needed to try to get
that information because he has every
right right to see it as a response to
this and he says look this is you don't
get to not tell the rest of the Intel
committee and then she doesn't then just
go coordinate with the President on
something that is currently at issue in
investigation and I hate to say this but
Adams ship is not entirely incorrect
here is the Adam Schiff Democratic
California and I can't stand Adam Schiff
but everybody's lying it's the worst
okay it's really impossible for us to
evaluate any of the merits of what the
chairman has said but I can't say this
the Chairman will need to decide whether
he is the chairman of an independent
investigation into conduct which
includes allegations of potential
coordination between the Trump campaign
and the Russians war he is going to act
as a surrogate of the white house
because he cannot do both and they go
there how dare shift go after Nunez for
all of this okay you know what okay see
this I don't have my shoe with me this
is the shoe put it on the other foot you
see the shoe put it on the other foot
let's pretend for a second there was
some independent investigation of Barack
Obama going on okay and Barack Obama
made an allegation that Republicans were
targeting him okay and the head of the
investigation into that thing then went
to the white house without telling the
other Republican members of the
committee breached the president on all
that stuff and then came back with a
bunch of talking points that helped the
president would you be okay with that I
wouldn't be okay with that everybody
needs to stop with this crap what is
true is for what is false is false and
when people claim now Trump is claiming
is vindicated he's not vindicated okay
Trump is claiming vindication on
something where he's not vindicated and
I'll explain the lightest matters in a
second and it's not just all talk in
jabber okay here's from saying he was
vindicated
I some what do I must tell you I some
what do I very much appreciated the fact
that they found what they found like I
said what do I somewhat to okay well of
course he feels vindicated because
anything that provides him any fig leaf
under which to hide makes him feel
vindicated now i'm going to explain the
second while this matters and why it's
not just a bunch of Jabbar and well i
think there is something that is deep at
stake that I don't like okay but first I
have but first I want to say thank you
to our advertisers over at Zeile so ze
elle.com promo code Ben will get you 25
bucks off a massage is healed I can I
eat one right now everybody my family
has used the old zeal is fantastic you
schedule a massage for your house they
do a background check on you to make
sure that you're not some sort of
creeper but the people who come and give
you them sudden they're all
professionally licensed masseuses we've
had four or five different masseuses you
actually do massages on people in my
family my sister has gotten a massage to
resile I think to actually through Zeile
my father has had one I've had one my
wife has had one my mother-in-law has
had 10 is a fantastic service and again
not only is it cheaper than having to go
to a spa it also means you don't have to
wait in line at this by actually gets a
schedule it at your house to bring all
the materials they bring the table they
bring the bring the soothing music the
whole deal and it is just an excellent
service it makes it one of the things
that I like to say is that in life there
are certain things that just make you
feel rich even if you're not and zero is
one of those things as he always is deal
is one of the things that will make you
feel not only rich but healthier after
you use it to start off right now you go
to ze l-com make sure to click Add promo
code to check out and use my name Ben
you get 25 bucks off your first massage
by doing that some pretty solid deal ze
l-com zeal calm promo code Ben and you
can use their iphone or android app and
you get that that special offer with
promo code button that lets them know
that we sent you as a thank you to them
ok so the reason that all of this is
important and then i have to go to
another set of lies on Trump care now
the Democrats are telling the reason all
this is important is because
unfortunately president Trump has an
extraordinarily casual relationship with
the truth that's not good for a
Republican president if you want him to
succeed he needs to have a certain level
of public trust
that level of public trust can only only
be built if he says true things I didn't
interview with Time magazine did
president Trump today and this interview
is just it's just awful okay again I
have a very consistent standard here
when people tell the truth I like it
when people lie when they obfuscate I
don't so Trump honest to god the man
treats the truth like a he treats
the truth like a and he leaves
some money on the bedside stand in
pursuit of his actual goal which is
power and you may like the things that
he does with that but let's not pretend
the truth is not truth Democrats do the
same thing then I don't want to pretend
that this is solely Trump okay Democrats
do the same thing politicians do it all
the time but he's supposed to be
somebody who represents me and
represents the American people and he is
and he's instead pursuing whatever
idiocy comes into his mind at the given
time I'm really angry about this because
it's undermining what could be a great
agenda it's undermining what could be
great policies it's undermining true
things that need to be said because he
can't keep his mouth shut okay it's
really frustrating it's really
frustrating so two things one Trump
number one will say things that are just
blatantly untrue and then you will
defend them all the way down the line
and to trump mistakes predicting things
for saying true things those are not the
same thing and they're not the same
thing Donald Trump for example says
things like I was totally right about
breakfast they eat it he predicted
brexit in March 2016 congratulations
does that mean that he said true things
about Ted Cruz's father no it doesn't
mean he's a truth-telling person it
means they made a good prediction on
brexit okay bookies do it all the time
would you trust a bookie to take care of
your kids at night and not the same
thing just because you predict things
and I shouldn't say all the things you
predict some things correctly that does
not mean that you are a trustworthy
person and the reason that I say this is
because in this interview Trump says
he's a very instinctual person but my
instinct turns out to be right so he
just says things without any sort of
verification number one he says he was
asked about about the Obama wiretap
Trump Tower comments he said we will see
what happens look I predicted a lot of
things that took a little bit of time
okay that was not a prediction that was
a claim of fact about what has already
happened if I say that the war of 1812
was not engaged in an 18-12 a ton of
prediction that's a misstatement of fact
if I say the Civil War didn't happen
the North and the South in America my
answer to that cannot be afterward well
you know eventually I'll be proved right
no no and she's not true and he's
supposed to know he's the president okay
when he still says in this interview
that he'll be proved right about his
unsubstantiated claim of 3 million
undocumented votes in the 2016 election
no you don't have any evidence of that
and you claims that it happened so you
have to provide evidence of that I like
evidence I like fact don't tell me that
the narrative is true and the facts are
false is a bunch of crap he justified
again the Ted Cruz again okk year after
it happened the Ted Cruz's father
murdered you have K garbage he called
the he said that he said quote that was
in the newspaper that was in a newspaper
number one was in the National Enquirer
number two so the hell what you're the
one to keep saying that the news is fake
news and you can't trust what you read
in the newspaper unless apparently to
the National Enquirer in the same
interview he called The Wall Street
Journal fake news so let's just to get
this straight the National Enquirer is
real news but the wall street journal is
fake news and when he's asked about his
accusations at British intelligence was
complicit in wiretapping and it goes why
do you say I have to apologize I'm just
quoting the newspaper just like I quoted
the judge the other day judge napolitano
you're the president you can pick up the
phone and find out whether this is true
don't we have some responsibility to the
truth and look this is not about hurting
Trump the minute he starts doing good
things I'm more than happy to praise Him
I want I want to praise Him okay I want
the president to do good things so I can
praise him but I'm not going to praise
him lying just because it benefits my
side that's a bunch of horse manure and
people who do that are complicit in
destroying their own credibility and the
credibility of politics we cannot have
conversations with each other if all we
do is say the facts don't matter all
that matters is my narrative if that's
the case the facts don't matter at all
and we cannot have a conversation in the
slightest okay with that ran ton I now
want to move on to trump care and where
that is because that is still moving
along and there's a lot of controversial
war that's going and a big why that is
currently happening from the left on
Trump care we'll talk about that in just
a second but for that you have to go
over to daily wired.com and become a
subscriber daily wire.com eight dollars
a month gets you a subscription if you
want an annual subscription over at
daily wire then you can get a free
signed copy of reasons to vote Democrat
a comprehensive
our very own Michael mole just a
brilliant thorough piece of literature
on why do vote Democrat and the Amazon
bestseller sold tens of thousands of
copies the dudes getting rich off of it
which was shocking but in any case daily
wire.com you get a free copy it's a lot
of fun eight dollars a month and annual
subscribers get that copy of that book
if you if you just want to listen the
rest of the show a little bit later you
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud and you
can check out the show over there leave
review at iTunes we do appreciate it and
this is the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
you